foreign
my name is Shri I'm from Illinois
we just ended a 15 year old marriage and
we'd have two kids I'm trying to manage
expectations
um with my ex so I know like the
expectations were like a big
point of resentment for me
so I'm trying to practice no
expectations and having high acceptance
at the same time I don't know how to
manage kids expectations should I let
them
should I let them disappoint and sooner
or later they will come to terms or
should I just manage
having a backup plan uh try I mean I do
not want to cover up for him but at the
same time it makes me pain for the kids
to be disappointed in certain ways so
how do I navigate trying to be
um equal sharing responsibilities of
family
which is my primary value and at the
same time I can't push this value on my
ex so how do I navigate on day-to-day
life holding the expectations and
accountability for him at the same time
not going into insane Loop Dr Warren it
sounds to me like Shri is beginning to
understand that acceptance is sort of
this tool to declutter your expectations
because she also realize those
expectations are a gateway to
disappointment having all these
expectations of your ex of your current
partner of your kids sometimes it makes
sense but it's also going to make you
angry it's going to make you upset it's
going to make you discontented but she
did bring up this word resentment I
don't want to resent my ex can we talk
about resentment oh yeah
especially in a situation like hers
where
oftentimes what I see in divorces or in
people who have been in relationships
for a longer period of time who may have
children is that the fantasy
addictive nature of love that happens
early on usually in the honeymoon phase
has dissipated because they've been
together for a long time and so what
happens in the breakup is there is so
much more anger about
false promises about expectations that
were never met about a lifestyle that
had such hopeful positive future ideals
tied to it that are no longer going to
be
and so a lot of
the process of healing after a divorce
is going to include
not just getting over your ex but
getting over everything that encompassed
the life you had with your ex
um
your home your family your roles as
co-parents
all of that is probably shifting and so
when it comes to resentment
the number one thing I tell people when
they're really angry is this
the opposite of love is not hate
the opposite of Love and Hate
is indifference
um
your goal is to come to a place in
yourself where you look at your ex and
you look at your old life in all of its
brutal and wonderful glory and say I see
it I experienced it and it's not going
to affect me anymore
um
I love how she said lowering her
expectations but living with a high
level of acceptance and Josh and I we
often talk about living with low
expectations but high standards I think
acceptance might be a better word there
because this the more we can accept the
more we can kind of find that
indifference where it's not making us
happy it's not making us sad we're just
accepting what's happening to us now she
brings up brings up the kids and she
talked about you know how does she
manage her kids and how does she manage
her kids expectations oh man I think
about like when my mom and dad split up
it drives me crazy that like they would
totally just talk trash about each other
um constantly and
um it really affected me because I would
look at my parents differently so with
SRI here you know I think the best thing
you can do for your children which it's
so easy to give advice about kids when I
don't have any
um but the best thing to do for the kids
here is like you know remind your kids
like yes your father loves you yes your
father wants the best for you and try to
keep the negativity out of it you don't
want to lie to the kids no um but you
certainly don't have to you know Badger
or you know bash their their dad
um when he does something that when he
doesn't mean an expectation yeah your
kids are going to have expectations for
sure you don't need to hand them your
expectations as well yeah another thing
I'd add to is is never underestimate the
power we have to solicit cooperation by
asking questions rather than making
demands so if you're expecting something
from someone and they're not coming
through it can be helpful to say hey is
there something going on that's making
this an unattainable goal for you that's
making this unrealistic am I asking for
too much or asking for it in a way that
just doesn't work for you or is there
something I could do to support here's
what I need here's what I'm expecting I
mean do we need to have a conversation
about that and whether or not those
things need to be changed and sometimes
when you can just put a question mark at
the end of those expectations and needs
it can open that other person up and say
yeah you know what I I am struggling I
don't I don't think I can do Monday
Wednesday and Friday I I got I need to
change it up because of my schedule and
this and that and that and this and then
that can create the space for new
possibilities to arise that's never a
guarantee but that's what makes it so
powerful because when we argue when we
debate when we list our demands that's
the realm of guarantee that's the realm
of familiarity but that's also the realm
where we repeat the same old results
it's the questions it's the uncertainty
it's the risk of vulnerability and
openness that creates the space for
something new
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free